forget green screens today we're going
to be talking about the 100 million
dollar Dome that's destroying them and
no I'm not talking about a Sci-Fi weapon
or a natural disaster I'm talking about
the Revolutionary Innovation that's
transforming the way filmmakers create
immersive and realistic environments for
their stories I'm talking about the
volume the secret to film is that it's
an illusion there's nothing like it that
takes your breath away you have the
illusion of movement against the
illusion of space and time it's really
an end-to-end solution
it's just an amazing piece of technology
it transports you somewhere it makes you
feel like you're there
the volume is the Epic sounding name
given to a massive LED video wall that
surrounds a circular stage creating a
360 degree virtual backdrop that can
display any location or scene imaginable
it was developed by industrial Light and
Magic the visual effects company founded
by George Lucas and it was first used
extensively on the hit Disney plus
series The Mandalorian since then it's
been used on several other projects such
as Thor love and thunder the Batman the
book of Boba Fett Obi-Wan Kenobi Percy
Jackson and the Olympians and more but
what makes the volume so special and why
is it better than the traditional green
screen technique well there are several
advantages and disadvantages of using a
green screen and Film Production let's
take a look at some of them
[Music]
foreign
advantages of using a green screen is
that it allows filmmakers to shoot
scenes that would otherwise be
impossible and practical or too
expensive to film in real locations for
example if you want to show your
characters flying in space fighting in a
fantasy world or exploring an ancient
ruin you can simply film them in front
of a green canvas and then replace it
with a digital background later on in
post-production this gives you a lot of
creative freedom and flexibility to tell
any story you want however using a green
screen also comes with some significant
drawbacks one of them is that it
requires a lot of lighting to make the
green color uniform and bright enough to
be easily removed this can create
problems with color spill which is when
the green light reflects onto other
parts of the set or onto the actor's
skin hair or clothing this can make the
final result look unnatural and
unconvincing especially in the case of a
television series like the Mandalorian
whose main character always wears a set
of Highly reflective armor if this show
had been filmed with a traditional green
screen the titular character likely
would have looked more like this
another drawback of using a green screen
is that it can make the actress
performance more difficult and less
realistic since they're acting in front
of a blank wall they have to rely on
their imagination and direction to
visualize what they're supposed to see
and react to this can be challenging or
frustrating for some actors especially
if they have to interact with objects or
characters that aren't physically on the
set you can also make the director's job
harder as they have to communicate their
Vision clearly and constantly monitor
the camera angles and movements to make
sure they match with the intended
background this is where the volume
comes in handy the volume solves many of
these problems by using high definition
LED screens that display photorealistic
images of the desired background in real
time the images are generated by a video
game engine called Unreal Engine which
allows for dynamic lighting Shadows
Reflections and Parallax effects the
images also change according to the
camera's position and orientation
creating a sense of depth and
perspective the volume offers several
benefits over using a green screen one
of them is that it provides natural
lighting for the actors and the set
eliminating the need for excessive
artificial lighting and reducing color
spill another benefit is that it gives
the actor something tangible and
realistic to look at and interact with
enhancing their performance and emotion
it also gives the director more creative
control and feedback over the scene as
they can see what the final result will
look like on set and make adjustments
accordingly the volume also saves time
and money in post-production as it
reduces or eliminates the need for
Chroma keying rotoscoping compositing
and other visual effects processes that
are usually required when using a green
screen in some cases the shots capture
on the volume are considered final or
near final meaning that they don't need
any further editing or enhancement of
course the volume isn't perfect either
it also has some limitations and
challenges that need to be addressed one
of them is that it's very expensive to
build and operate According to some
reports each volume costs around 100
million dollars to construct and
requires a lot of power and maintenance
it also takes up a lot of space and can
only accommodate a limited number of
actors and props on stage another
limitation of the volume is that it can
still look artificial or fake in some
situations for example if there are
fast-moving objects or characters on
screen that can create motion blur or
flicker on the LED panels also if there
are fine details or edges on the actors
or the set they can create aliasing or
jagged lines on the screen these issues
can be fixed or minimized by using
higher resolution screens faster refresh
rates anti-aliasing filters and other
techniques but they can still be
noticeable and distracting for some
viewers the volume also isn't suitable
for every type of scene or genre for
instance if the scene requires a lot of
physical interaction with the
environment such as climbing jumping or
falling it might be safer and more
realistic to the Practical set or a
stunt double also if the scene is set in
a very dark or nighttime location the
brightness of the LED screens might be
too high and create unwanted glare or
contrast in these cases using a green
screen or a blue screen might be a
better option the volume is a remarkable
Innovation that's changing the way
filmmakers create immersive and
realistic environments for their stories
although it isn't a one size fits-all
solution it's still a powerful tool that
can be used to make some really
compelling Illusions the secret to film
is is that it's a new version and with
the volume the illusion is more
convincing than ever thanks for watching
and see you next time
[Music]